you talked a lot about producing for
television yet Sinha dopes was your
first experience as a director all right
yes okay so how is being the director
different than being the producer um
that's a great question uh let's see
well in it's almost like I've seen my
career as sort of walking through doors
on my way to my ultimate goal which has
always been to direct and early on in my
career as I SAT there I ran a theater
company and had to close it because it I
couldn't turn a profit on it and I SAT
there and said you know how can I get
myself to that that area you know to
directing and it's you know it's a
difficult path and I came up with the
idea of as I as I said in a previous
answer that i was going to learn
everything that goes on and then
ultimately i would get to a point where
i would be so valuable to a project that
they would give me they would want all
of my experience they would give me the
director job because they knew that in
my hands i was going to deliver what I
said I could deliver and it was almost
like I mean at 22 years old out of
college I could have said I'm ready now
but there's no way I was ready I didn't
have even close to the amount of
knowledge about the process that I do
now and so I started about the process
you know taking the one job that I
thought would I could do the best which
was working as a first ad and I did my
400 days it got in the DGA and you know
went through that whole process made
think it had twenty-something features
as a first ad and I got to the point
where I was like okay I've got this down
and you know I'm ready to take the next
step and the next step up from ad is upm
unit production manager so I understood
the world of the scent I understood you
know what time the grips had to show up
to get the set you know built and lit
what time the camera guys needed to
start building their cameras but
I had no idea about the world of
budgeting you know scheduling dealing
with contracts all of that stuff so as I
step through that door of being an ad
and then into the world of being a upm a
whole nother level opened up where it
was like okay now I see what goes on in
the office and now I see you know what a
production coordinator is doing all day
and you know hiring everyone use the
process of hiring every single person on
the set and then obviously the next step
above that is a line producer so when I
start working as you p.m. then you start
working as a line producer and you start
dealing with actually dealing with the
money people you know not just asking
for the money but also the payment
schedules and the budgets and all of
these you know all those fun things so
it's been a cumulative process of like
every door that I step through there's a
whole nother world of things that you're
like oh okay well I didn't realize this
was there and as you sort of you know I
hesitate to say I mastered them but I've
definitely gotten comfortable with those
you know those job descriptions you know
you add on the next level so going from
82 upm to line producer to producer and
then getting back to the opportunity of
being able to direct when I was able to
walk in to you know this situation and
say look you know I'm going to be able
to deliver a show you know it's going to
happen I will give you a finished
product that's going to look great and
this is now my director side this is my
artistic interpretation you know do you
believe in my interpretation of material
do you trust my judgment on actors
getting more into the creative side of
it you know was the final piece in the
puzzle so I guess the short shorter
answer to your question is the
difference between producing directing I
think you know you as a director you
need to know all of those elements that
you have as a producer but you're given
that creative input that is for me it's
like you know that was the final piece
of the puzzle that it makes you feel
hole in the process that not only do I
understand the business side of it and
why these things happen but I also
have this creative side that I want to
bring to it and that's what sort of
makes the project your own you know
where you're like yep that was you know
that's a film by me or a TV show by me
because you put that final creative
stamp on it
you